the product rule was to do with
differentiating things that are as the
name suggests something times something
else right the quotient rule is not
something time something else it's
something divided by something else
right
so the way I way to prove this for you
is by starting out by differentiating
setting out to differentiate a question
now for reasons that will become clear
in about 45 seconds rather than the TV
says view at V which is the letter type
that using all the way along I'll learn
to find these first as P and Q so I'll
write it like this again I'm writing it
in function notation for P times X
that's P is a function of X Q is also a
function of X so P over Q it's quotient
what am I going to do with it okay now
as I said before the question rule
follows immediately from the product
rule so we've know we've seeded so many
thousands of times that many techniques
in mathematics boil down to turning a
problem you don't know how to do into
one that you do know how to do so I'm
going to write this quotient as a
product could I learn how to deal with
products so instead of writing this is
something divided by something I'm going
to write the division part of this as a
multiplication so what would I have to
multiply this by that would achieve the
same effect
as dividing by Q of X what I love Q of X
would do the job right if I said x what
over Q of X that's a product which
produces the same result as this
question however I'm going to do one
slightly different thing rather write it
as 1 over Q of X I'm going to write it
as Q of X to the power of negative 1 the
reason why is because in terms of
differentiating I know what to do with
powers are quite good at those right so
trying to draw all all this prior
knowledge that I used to have to be able
to tackle this new problem ok so why is
it not choose you would V even though
I've been using them quite consistently
and I will by the end of this
answer to use product rule ID to decide
the two parts of the product as you
would leave so I'm going to call this
guy you and we call this whole thing
here including the negative one at all
that's my V okay so you can see why I
didn't want to call if this is you and
this is V to the power of negative one I
don't know what decide V is better than
that such a bad idea okay which I ran
into before so this is a product down so
I can just treat this like a normal
product right the derivative of a
product is V U - plus U V - yes so let's
walk through this one step at a time
v I'm just going to write what V is
it's Q of X to the power of negative one
there's the V what's here - in this case
well it's the difference the derivative
of this thing with respect to X that I
don't know what P is but I know notation
to define or to describe the derivative
of P I just write P - so far so good so
this is the and I'll even write it again
this is the V and you - of collateral
now I need the U at the reaction let's
keep going the U is just P of X okay now
here is the tricky part you really need
to have your own kekeke a board for this
part other that's alright V - V -
however as you noticed since other
problems that you've already been in
country frequently to do product or
successfully you need to do chain rule
once or twice in the middle of doing
product rule so that's why we did it in
the order that we've done and this is
one of those cases right do you notice
this you've got a function of X and it's
being it's having another function
namely this applied to it so this V is a
function on the function so therefore
I've got to use function function let's
chain rule so help me out if that's V
how I work out V -
how do i do chain rule yeah suspect okay
so the first thing I do with chain rule
is work out the decide then I work out
the derivative of the outside well the
inside is just Q of X so the derivative
of the inside is just Q - that's the
derivative of the inside now I do the
outside well it's something to the power
of negative one this is why I wrote it
in index form rather there's one over
something as a fraction you're going to
bring that power at the front and reduce
the power by one do you agree so
interest I can I just watch out because
we've used function notation we have a
lot of brackets flying around so I'm
going to use three levels of brackets
here so my first one is going to be a
curly brace okay I'm going to bring that
negative one the power out to be the
front the coefficient so that's minus
one yep and there's this whole thing so
that's this whole thing its power gets
reduced by one so what be negative what
anymore it'll be negative three Becca
okay now we've really done all the hard
parts now I just need to tidy things up
a teeny bit okay I've accomplished what
I needed to highlight the fact that
these these are all functions okay so
I'm now going to on the next line I'm
going to write it without function
notation it's a bit tiresome isn't it
I've written function of X of X I mean
comes out of five clients I don't need
to do this anymore okay this here is Q
to the negative 1 times P - yeah you
said you see why I don't
I got a huge fan of nationalism to make
it really obvious I'm going to put a
little put tails on negative 1 okay let
me hear what I got oh my god
I've got P Q - and then in here I've got
negative Q to the negative 2
have a look so far well I've actually
done any computation I've just rewritten
it a bit tinier way okay I can go a step
further see these negative powers right
I usually dislike writing things with
negative powers I usually prefer to
write to this fraction in fact the only
reason I write things in negative powers
is so I could differentiate okay so I'm
going to get rid of all of the negative
powers now this makes this P - odd Q yes
okay here I've got P Q - on I should
really write this motor sign over here
actually on Q squared are you happy with
that so look okay so far I've got two
fractions the normal thing I do when
I've got two fractions is I want to seek
to combine them what I need to do to
combine them call the denominator in
this case the easiest common denominator
is Yusuke that's really easy to do I
don't have to muck with this guy at all
all I have to do is multiply this guy by
Q over Q so I just vote don't blink or
you'll miss it
I'm just going to multiply this by Q and
this bike you okay with that and now I
can put it all together as one fraction
that's the derivative of P on Q now like
I said before I was going to end with
using V because I performed that you've
seen peripheral in and you will
immediately see how similar but
different this is to the product rule
right so if I replaced my Peas with EU
and my cues with a V like so then this
looks like it's going to be all look
surprise surprise above a game and a V
squared on the bottom okay so let's
point out some things here before we
finish okay for starters it's not quite
a bull visit like we saw before it's a
little bit different has a different
it's also started citizens denominator
you divide by V squared that's a big
obvious change most people find that
quite easy to remember because what the
quotient rule is a question that's nice
isn't it in addition to that please
though maybe you want to highlight
okay please note there's a minus sign
here that's different from the product
rule okay and that's an easy thing to
forget no excuses for it you have the
reference sheet but again this is not
hard to remember you using so many
hundreds and thousands of times it will
start to seep into your brain okay so
it's a very squared one more thing to
point out for you the product rule gives
you this you the fee you - you - have
you already noticed doesn't matter which
one you or V is does it right you could
initation
you would get the same thing okay -
notice that instead of rule if you'd get
move right where'd you get exactly the
same thing you're adding it right at an
addition could be done either way and
the reason for that the reason why the
product rule is symmetrical in that way
is because products are symmetrical
yuto's V is the same as V times u so no
difference however that's not the case
over here is it right you over V not the
same as the over you